5 years ago this comedian was kicked off
stage at Columbia University mid show
for making jokes about why being gay
must not be a choice actually we have a
change of program I'm sorry the tech has
to leave for an event the tech has to
leave yeah they better be leaving no
they have a dance manath on tomorrow
they have a so why why did this come up
now because they have to leave earlier
than expected is it because I'm talking
about uncomfortable stuff Nish Patel
recently returned to the scene of the
crime to relive the memory of the night
he was removed including the insane
aftermath of this story going viral this
is how I figured out that being gay
can't be a choice cuz no one would
choose to be gay if they're already
black I'm not wrong no one's doubling
down on hardship no black dude ever
wakes up looks in the mirror and thinks
you know what this black too
easy